Film Courage: How did making your first feature
film and then getting feedback on that film
impact how you write things now?
Chris von Hoffmann, horror writer/director:
Oh hugely, massively because with making DRIFTER,
I’m going to be very, very honest I was
not focusing that much on screenplay, on pedestrian
narrative, on plotting, on character development.
I was very much focused on a cold exercise
in style.
Very much making scene after scene of stuff
that I love and have a thin story stitched
together with duct tape, that was 100% the
intention of that movie.
But I think we were getting a lot of feedback
when we were editing it and we knew and we
knew that there were some irreparable problems
that were dictated by the weakness of the
screenplay and kind of shot myself in the
foot a little bit by rushing into it because
people were…they were just taking the movie
so seriously they were being so film school
analytical about so many things because if
there is a story it’s one of those kind
of movies that start off as one thing and
by the end it’s a very much different thing,
it keeps on transforming itself sort of like
this hybrid, genre mashup which is definitely
the movie I wanted to make at the time.
I still think it’s a fun picture when I
watch it…”picture.”
I sound like I’m in the 40’s when I said
that.
But with MONSTER PARTY, that was a really
wonderful experience because there is much
more pressure on that movie, I have a lot
of producers involved, a lot of great people
involved that have much more experience than
I am.
People who are extremely brutally honest from
the word go, from the writing stage, to the
filming of it, to the editing of it, to the
sound, the music, everything.
I had people watching every element of that
movie.
And they were all very strong collaborators,
I really love working with these guys.
I think
I was always wanting those heavy-hitting cut-throat
producers that were going to say “Chris,
this is not working.
You have to fix this because you are going
to shoot yourself in the foot later on the
editing.”
And I had a lot of that on MONSTER PARTY,
because you get so inside the movie and you
need those outside perspectives and I didn’t
really have that much on DRIFTER because we
were all friends and we kind of all came up
together so I don’t think they were being
as harsh as they should have been.
With MONSTER PARTY that was not the case,
but I think that was right in the long run
because at the end of the day it’s the movie.
It’s not your auteur personality, it’s
not your cool stylist, it’s the movie.
I mean at a certain point it’s not even
your movie anymore, it has to be as accessible
as possible and MONSTER PARTY was a great
transition for me, it was almost like a new
chapter in my life to really explore new territory
and go back to the roots of the storytelling
I was attracted to and approach it from a
much more mature angle and can I have the
soundtrack and the style organically climb
inside the movie a little bit and not hijack
the movie like DRIFTER .
I’m very proud of the experience with MONSTER
PARTY, very proud of the movie.
Film Courage: Do you think most of your characters…let’s
say any characters in any of your features
do they go through the hero’s journey.
Because in some ways it’s different, a horror
movie is not going to end in a great light
where this hero has realized their potential
or saved something and it’s often not the
case.
Chris: With DRIFTER I was trying to do that.
But MONSTER PARY I would definitely say has
a hero’s journey.
But I am very attracted to stories that are
populated by, I like morality tales.
I like movies that have a moral tightrope
that the characters are walking that the lead
character might do something that you might
not agree with and it might be a little bit
messed up and I’m going to challenge you
if you still want to go on the ride with him.
A really random example that I bring up because
it’s so notorious for being so bad it’s
good which I think it a really genuinely fun
movie is SHOWGIRLS, which I love SHOWGIRLS,
it’s great.
I’m not saying that ironically, I really
love that movie.
The first time I saw it was with my Mother,
it was a very random, weird experience.
But what’s really fascinating about that
movie and what I’m trying to do and what
I’m trying to do with MONSTER PARTY a lot
was every character in that movie was kind
of like has badness in them.
I mean they might disguise it but they are
all kind of very…they have bad, bad qualities
about them, even Nomi (the main character
played by Elizabeth Berkley) and the only
innocent character in that movie is the girl
who is the make-up artist and she gets punished
for being innocent in this world of horrible
people.
She gets punished quite horribly and people
forget about that really horrible scene in
the third act with her and the rock star guy.
That’s a very eye-opening, vicious scene
where she gets punished for being good, a
good pure person around these terrible people
including the lead character.
That’s sort of what I tried to dabble in
with monster party where its very flawed people
against even more flawed people and the people
you think would not be flawed were way more
flawed than you possibly could imagine but
there are a couple very innocent people in
the movie who get extremely punished for being
very genuine.
It sounds like a sick way of looking at things,
that’s always been sort of the outlook I
saw the world in where sometimes good deeds
go, like they always say “No good deed goes
unpunished” or whatever.
And innocent people paying the price for being
what they are and bad people having this power
and the moral corruption of the world in our
society and our generation and I’m always
trying to make some sort of bold statement
about how I see, I’m not just trying to
make sort of cool genre movies and violence
and cool stuff.
That’s all fun but I am trying to sneak
in a very bold statement about how I see the
world because a lot of it is very personal.
As whacked out as some of the stuff is it
is very, very personal about the kind of tone
and the kind of nature of certain lead characters
that we’re supposed to be rooting for.
I think when you’re writing stories you
have put all of your good traits on screen
but you also have to put a lot of your bad
traits on screen and no one wants to see just
good traits.
You almost embarrass yourself by putting in
really bad traits about yourself.
Do it in a very fun, kind of accessible way
but those kind of stories I’ve always been
kind of attracted to.
Film Courage: Or CARRIE.
Chris: Yes, CARRIE is great.
Film Courage: Being punished at home, being
punished at high school.
Chris: That’s such a cynical story and then
she has no other options but to terrorize
her prom and then she pays the price for it.
I mean that’s such a sad, great morality
tale.
Because everyone has flaws and everyone has
darkness inside of them, some people do a
better job disguising them.
But I like movies that really push the boundaries
of what our protagonist are capable of and
somewhat bad people against worst people.
I’ve just always been attracted to that
kind of storytelling.
Film Courage: Right and when you see the bad
people are the ones that are the stereotypical
ones that if you saw them in a dark alley
[you’d go the other way] and sometimes those
aren’t the ones that are the worst, it’s
the ones whom you would think are a little
more trustworthy.
Chris: Yes.
One of my favorite directors is Larry Clark
and films like BULLY and KIDS and KENT PARK,
those films are very disturbing experiences
but they are characters that…I grew up around
people very much around those kind of people.
My brother was very friends with those kind
of kids.
So I think a lot of that kind of stuff, hearing
very revolting things that these kids would
say and seeing stuff that they would do and
hearing stories about them (what they would
do) and I think a lot of that stuff I try
to translate in a cinematic format and go
back to that…It just comes from growing
up and the kind of people I was around in
high school and the things that I saw and
just really disturbing, tragic things that
were happening with people and at a certain
point you just can’t quite see the world
any other ways until you get into your later
years but I’m just stemming about how the
world was around me growing up, the kind of
people that I interacted with, and the kind
that I grew up around and the people’s houses
that I went to and the kind of stuff I saw
and the really whacked out, dysfunctional
things that were happening inside these houses
and these kids.
I don’t know, I’m just very attracted
to that kind of stuff and making it as grounded
as possible in a cinematic kind of way.